I'm Nathan Smith I'm an associate
curator in the dinosaur Institute at the
Natural History Museum of Los Angeles
County I'm here to talk to you about
every dinosaur that you can find in the
Jurassic Park films welcome to Jurassic
Park brachiosaur was a member of the
sauropod group so these are the huge
long necked plant eaters Rekha Soros was
one of the animals with longer four
limbs and a vertically held neck that
are probably used for hi browsing so in
the first Jurassic Park movie you see it
up there in the tops of the trees
sneezing on the kids
[Music]
Parasaurolophus is one of the crested
duck-billed dinosaurs they have kind of
a long gait crest on their head some of
these might have been used for
vocalization or also display
characteristics for kind of recognizing
their own species or for a sexual
display they also had a really amazing
battery of teeth that helped them grind
up plant material Velociraptor is
probably the most famous dinosaur from
Jurassic Park in real life Velociraptor
was a much smaller animal probably about
the size of a really big turkey one of
the most interesting things about it is
that we know this animal and the group
it belongs to were very close relatives
of birds and we actually have evidence
now that came out since the first film
that Velociraptor probably was at least
partially covered in feathers there are
actually bony quill knobs that are
present on its forearm Velociraptor was
kind of a fleet-footed fast animal
possibly more intelligent than some
other dinosaurs I'm not sure if they
were really as hyper intelligent as
they're portrayed in the film but
there's got to be a little artistic
license with that
[Music]
Triceratops is another iconic dinosaur
known from the Late Cretaceous Hell
Creek Formation
you know three very large horns and the
frill on the back this is an animal that
lived alongside Tyrannosaurus and is
often depicted with Tyrannosaurus and it
plays a big role in the early Jurassic
Park films as well it's actually an
animal that gets sick because of the
plant life that's been reproduced
alongside the dinosaurs in the first
film Tyrannosaurus Rex one of the most
popular dinosaurs of all time or the the
greats of the Jurassic Park film
franchise t-rex is always kind of
portrayed as the top dinosaur because
for the longest time it was the largest
predatory dinosaur that we knew of
um recent discoveries kind of only in
the past 15 or 20 years have shown that
there are several other species of large
carnivorous dinosaur that are now vying
for that title so it's possible that
Tyrannosaurus has been dethroned as the
largest carnivore so there's a big point
made in the first film that t-rex had
relatively poor vision and there is some
evidence that it's other senses might
have been a little more well-developed
its sense of smell for instance but I
find it a little unlikely that t-rex
would have been unable to see some of
the humans standing right in front of it
so in the second Jurassic Park film
t-rex actually gets loose I think in San
Diego and is running around downtown and
then the suburbs again I think this is
an animal that probably would have been
more confused than anything else and
probably would have been not quite on a
rampage but just trying to get out of
there and away from everybody
[Music]
the local source also plays an iconic
role in Jurassic Park this is the animal
that takes out Nedry in one of the
Jurassic Park Jeeps during the rainstorm
now there is a little bit of artistic
license used for the portrayal of
Dilophosaurus because it probably did
not have that large frill and there's
also no evidence that it actually spats
poison however in reality some of the
specimens we have of Dilophosaurus were
much larger than the animal that's
portrayed in Jurassic Park so this is a
rare instance where the real thing might
have been even bigger and scarier it
probably would have likely attacked
without first alerting someone like
nedra to its presence without using a
frill and without using poison just the
old-fashioned coming right at them with
the teeth Gallimimus is an animal that
is known from one of the most famous
scenes of Jurassic Park where they're
actually hurting through an open field
and coming right after the protagonist
Alan Grant and the kids we learn shortly
after that they're actually fleeing from
a very hungry t-rex these are probably
correctly portrayed as being some of the
speediest animals that were around
during the Late Cretaceous Pro
Compsognathus is another animal that
plays a big role in Jurassic Park but
it's a little better described in the
actual book series so this is an animal
that's a very small carnivorous or
predatory dinosaur that is because of
its size maybe a little unassuming but
actually plays a major role both in the
beginning of the movie and at the end
and some of the folks that it takes out
we don't actually have direct evidence
of kind of social behavior or this kind
of gregariousness for pro Compsognathus
but we do have some evidence mass death
assemblages of the same species of
dinosaur that suggested these animals
might have hung out kind of in large
groups
[Music]
stegasaurus another iconic dinosaur one
of people's favorites this is kind of a
armor-plated dinosaur with a big series
of spikes on the back of its tail that
tail probably was very much a defensive
weapon for a Stegosaurus and and
certainly and it probably would have
used it to protect itself or to protect
its offspring one interesting fact about
Stegosaurus is that we still don't
really have a good handle on what those
plates were used for Pachycephalosaurus
another iconic dinosaur from Jurassic
Park and this is a member of the group
the Pachycephalosaurus that have the big
domed heads that often get portrayed in
popular media as being used for
head-butting each other or in Jurassic
Park for head barding those Rangers that
are trying to corral it or even ramming
into the side of a jeep door Cerreta
soros is an animal that's not quite as
well known it actually gets its name
from a horn that it has right on the tip
of the snout so it is a carnivorous
dinosaur a member of the theropod group
one interesting thing about Ceratosaurus
is that it represents an evolutionary
lineage that's gonna kind of branch off
and be a little bit separate from most
of the other carnivorous dinosaurs that
we see in the Jurassic Park films
[Music]
corythosaurus this animal is a
duck-billed dinosaur a member of the
Lambie soar group a plant-eater it's
doesn't have the really elongate press
of animals like augustin alofa soar
Parasaurolophus but it does have this
kind of high domed crest that actually
looks superficially kind of like what
you might see on a head of a cassowary
today
and Kyla Soros is another very famous
dinosaur so these are the heavily
armored dinosaurs or quadrupedal very
short and stout and Kyla Soros is very
well known for having this really robust
and big tail club situated the end of
the tail that it probably did use as a
defensive weapon although it's
interesting to note that not all in Kyla
sores possess that tail club Spinosaurus
this is an animal that plays a big role
in the third Jurassic Park film as kind
of the main villain of that film and
it's recognized by a huge sale that
comes across the back now that this is a
group of animals that we didn't really
know much about until recently with kind
of a flurry of new discoveries although
some of the first ones were discovered
almost a hundred years ago so
Spinosaurus and the larger group the
spinosaur day that it belongs to our
animals that were actually semi-aquatic
it's probably spending some time in the
water it's probably living and doing a
lot of it's feeding near the water and
including from some of the large fish
that were around during this time and
the Cretaceous whether or not it was
using that sale to help propel itself
through the water it's maybe a little
more doubtful and a little bit of
artistic license it's definitely the
case that these animals were more
adapted to life in the water than we had
previously given them credit for
so Spinosaurus is also famous from the
third Jurassic Park film for doing
battle with Tyrannosaurus one of the
largest dinosaurs of all time and recent
studies of new specimens of Spinosaurus
have also suggested that this animal
probably rivaled Tyrannosaurus in
science
[Music]
pteranodon shows up in a lot of the
Jurassic Park films it's probably one of
the most well known pterosaurs in the
films so this is an animal that's
actually not a dinosaur
it's a flying reptile a member of the
group Terra Soria
that are closely related to dinosaurs
but not dinosaurs themselves so in
Jurassic world there's also a very
famous scene where there's kind of a
Pteranodon attack on the main part of
the park where everybody's running
around and fleeing sometimes drinking
Han and we see Pteranodons swoop in and
actually grab people and pick them up
with their their hind feet which
definitely would have been impossible
these animals wouldn't have been able to
hold that much weight and they also
probably aren't using their feet for
grasping and attacking prey the way kind
of an eagle or a hawk would these
animals are probably attacking and
taking prey more similar to like a
modern stork Mosasaurus and Moses or iya
are not actually dinosaurs these are
animals that are actually closely
related to lizards so the movie kind of
portrays Mosasaurus as hunting its prey
near the water's edge and there there
might be some evidence for that because
many of them are found in the shallow
marine settings but it's also quite
likely that they were hunting other
animals actively in the water including
large a monoids that lived in this
Western interior Seaway Baryonyx is an
animal that shows up in one of the new
Jurassic Park films people will
immediately recognize it looks a lot
like Spinosaurus but just lacking that
giant sail and that is because it's a
member of that same group of dinosaurs
who spinosaur a day
[Music]
Carnotaurus is another animal that shows
up in the new Jurassic Park film this
animal gets its name for the kind of low
oldest horns that are sticking out just
above the eyes and if you're not looking
too quick this animal might look like
just another large predatory dinosaur
similar to t-rex you might even be
thrown off by the fact that this animal
it has very stubby forelegs
but this is actually a member of the
group called the abuse ORS which are
common during the Late Cretaceous on the
southern continents so they kind of in
many ways might have played a role
similar to t-rex but on the southern
continents during that time Allosaurus
is another well-known dinosaur so this
animal would have been a large bodied
predatory dinosaur kind of near the top
of the food chain during the Late
Jurassic would have been a contemporary
of animals like Stegosaurus Apatosaurus
Brachiosaurus Apatosaurus is another
large plant-eating sauropods source a
really long neck although compared to
Brachiosaurus this animal would have
held its neck more horizontally it's
possible that the difference in necks
between animals like Apatosaurus and
Brachiosaurus probably reflects feeding
differences these animals were probably
browsing it at different heights in the
trees that were around during the Late
Jurassic with Brachiosaurus kind of able
to reach a lot more of the high
vegetation so one of the most
interesting facts about Apatosaurus has
to do with another dinosaur brontosaurus
brontosaurus an Apatosaurus looked very
very similar and brontosaurus might
actually just be the adult version of
Apatosaurus since the PATA source had
been named first it had priority the
animals were kind of sunk into each
other as one species some new studies
have suggested that the specimens that
make up the material of brontosaurus may
be distinct enough to warrant them being
its own genus so in the past couple of
years brontosaurus has been brought back
whether it stays that way
who's to say
there are scenes in Jurassic Park where
BT Wong or dr. Henry talks about how
they've modified the genes of some of
these dinosaurs and that some of the
traits that they've selected for have
had unintended consequences which play
out throughout the film
so indominus rex in the new Jurassic
world movie allows the folks at the park
to kind of play around a little more and
actually combine together several
different dinosaurs to make something
even bigger and even scarier I think it
makes for a great villain in the movies
and it allows the film to go in a little
bit more of a horror movie direction
we're kind of a Frankenstein's monster
type style which allows for a lot more
suspenseful moments and kind of new
themes and topics in the film so there's
one scene in the film where indominus
kind of starts to communicate with the
velociraptors and we learned that
indominus rex actually has some
Velociraptor DNA that might be more of a
stretch than some of the other aspects
of the film but at this point we've kind
of already bought into the world they've
created Indo Raptor is the new
villainous dinosaur in the Jurassic
world's franchise on Kingdom and what
they seem to do is have taken indominus
rex and combined it with more Raptor DNA
so I almost kind of envision Christopher
Walken somewhere shaking a cowbell and
shouting I need more Raptor I need more
Raptor in this dinosaur so they kind of
crank up the Raptor a little bit and
create an animal that supposedly is even
more dangerous even more deadly for the
new film so I think Jurassic Park and
Jurassic world sometimes take a lot of
flak from scientists for inaccuracies
like any films do when they're trying to
portray Natural History but in reality
they've actually done a really great job
of trying to focus on getting the
anatomy of the animals right getting
inferences about their behavior their
vocalizations other things correct now
certainly they take artistic license
like any films do but more so than a lot
of the films that have featured
dinosaurs in the past Jurassic Park and
that franchise have have really tried to
involve the scientists and get accurate
depictions of what these animals might
have looked like and I think that just
adds to how fascinating the films
actually are
welcome to Jurassic world